Yo in this video I'm gonna talk about
the seven basic style rules that every
guy should know let's not waste any more
time let's get right into the video:
Hey! If you're new here on my channel, welcome!
I'm Daniel, consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos.
Now, let's start with the first basic rule
that every guy should know
Dress according to who you are and what you stand for. You always have the choice to
dress how you want but remember people
will always judge you based on your
appearance you know that saying where
they say don't judge a book by it's
cover well unfortunately most people in the world still do it. So they will make
assumptions on who you are based on the way that you dress, so don't overdress
don't under dress. Just dress yourself
according to who you are, according to
what fits well with you. In this way you
are letting people know who you are
before you even say a word.
Know your measurements. We all have different body types,right?
and that general small medium or
large it's not gonna look the same on
everybody because that's just the
general size. Some people have broader
shoulders, some guys have bigger arms
some guys have bigger lads. So it will
look different. You have to know your
measurements. If you know your
measurements then you'll know better
what kind of clothes will fit you and
look good on you. You can also then find
a good tailor. If you find a good tailor
they can make the clothes to fit you
perfectly and that'll just improve your
appearance immensely
Don't buy clothes that you like.
Buy clothes that you love
and that you use all the time. In this
way you save money and you don't buy
unnecessary stuff that you don't need
but you can invest that same money on
the items that you really love and
really need. So you buy better quality
clothing. There's a lot of videos out
there that says these are the clothes
you need, you need this, you need that you need this.
You don't need all the stuff. You
just need the basic clothing essentials
I have added my list for you in the video
description down below if you want to go
and check it out.
every guy needs to know
how to tie a tie. This is very basic when
it comes to style but I'm very surprised
because a lot of guys out there
have no clue. They have no clue how to tie a tie. If you're still young chances
are you'll find yourself in a situation
very soon where you will need to know
how to tie a tie.
Alright I am quickly gonna show you
Specifically a half Windsor knot. Because
that's the most easiest one to tie.
Alright so when you look at the tie:
you got two ends. You got the thin end and then you got a thick end. It's not that complicated.
What you want to do is bring the
thin end up to around here. Right, now the
first step of tying a tie is to take
this thin end and bring it underneath the long
thick end. Step two you take the
long thick end bring it underneath these
two and bring it over and back to where it was. So let's do that: under right through
these two and back to where it was.
Alright now these two fingers  are very
important because they keep the whole
knot together the whole time. Take the
thick end you bring it underneath this
whole knot area and you bring it over and
back to it was. Alright so let's do that.
Under and over to to where it was.
Last step you want to bring this whole
thick end and you want to bring it
under through these two and then it's
gonna be a loop and you put it through
the loop. So let's do that.
under through these two and then through the loop. Alright there we go and now
what you have to do is take this and
tighten it a little bit. Adjust it, adjust
it. Take this whole thin end and you hold
it and then you take the knot area and
you bring it up like that. Now you can
adjust this part here until you feel
very comfortable with it. All right bring
the color down. Okay now you have to
adjust it again. You're can't just leave it like this, right? So you have to adjust a
little bit. All right it's not perfect
but now you know how to tie and tie knot
Get some practicing and you'll get it
done. Alright let's move on
Every man needs to know how to choose
the right shoes for every occasion
for example Oxford Derby or loafers look
good at work or at business meetings
Leather boots, loafers and  sandals those
are great for casual situations like
socializing, depending on the weather.
Sneakers and chucks they're good for
everyday use. There are also different
types of a specific shoe styles within a specific style.
Let's look at boots for example you get boots for work
hiking, casual and smart.
Socks! if you wear socks in such a way where people
can see it it can either make or break
your clothing style. If you want to stay
safe remember these following rules: For
white socks wear it mainly with athletic
shoes. Then monotone black socks are for dress shoes and the color of your socks should
match the color of your suit pants and
if you wear shorts put hidden socks on
unless you're going to the gym.
Know your basic color combinations. if you know
which colors go together
when you wear your outfits it can greatly
enhance the look of your style. So let me
explain it very quickly: Almost all the
colors look really good with black and
white. Colors that fit well with beige
are black, brown, red, and green. Navy blue with white, beige, yellow, red and green
Yellow with black, brown, sky blue and
navy blue. Orange with white, yellow, black
and dark green. Brown with white, beige,
black, red and dark green. Dark green with
white, beige, sky blue, yellow, navy blue and black
Red with white, beige, sky blue, navy blue
black and brown. Sky blue looks good with
brown, dark green, dark purple, red and
beige. Purple with white, beige, sky blue,
pink, blue and brown. If you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers